oh this one is cute let's keep
you've got car insurance right buzz off
I doesn't sound good no peeking is bad
get rid of it I'm trying rowing up the
wind boat anywhere I can get it all
right I'm pulling over
[Applause]
did I get it no holster it's going it's
still here
I'm Sonic a little blue ball of super
energy in an extremely handsome package
and in order to save my planet I had to
come to yours where am i what yours it
is the rock president 20 minutes ago an
energy surge knocked out power across
the entire Pacific Northwest who's there
why are you hiding out in my garage the
entire military is after me good morning
my rural chump I'm going to give you
five seconds to tell me where it is oh
my god stop the car right now the
world's largest rubber band ball we
gotta see it no this is not some fun
family road trip Yeah right it was lame
give shot was cool though you can lay
low here for a while so what are we
gonna do now whoa let me show you how
it's done
[Music]
so should we get out of here yeah time
to go get away from me oh you've got car
insurance right
about to die
no but thank you for asking how are you
not dead I have no idea
[Applause]
[Music]
you throw your life away for this silly
little alien he's my friend
good times
my power that was an illegal left by the
way
using it to protect
glad
so you're supposed to be Tom's best
friend that he won't shut up about well
I don't see the appeal
that is very gross
[Music]